so many women just want to be absolutely
useless and be on Tik Tok all day and I
just grew up in a family that valued
hard work you were supposed to work hard
and do something and make something it
it wasn't even a man or a woman thing
and this isn't saying for women to be
super ambitious but I mean God give you
gave you a certain amount of talent so
so many of you guys are wasting it and
have done nothing with the talent that
God has given you poured into your
children poured into your husband poured
into freaking something I see I I
interview these lazy entitled women time
and time again and it's just like a
waste of space